chance dans le Donbass de fuir,
comme le raconte Jean-Michel
Leprince sur la ligne de front,
dans le Donbass.
- La gare de Pokrovsk est
la seule encore fonctionnelle
dans la région de Donetsk, et
ceci est un des derniers trains
d'évacuation de civils de cette
partie du Donbass sous contrôle
ukrainien menacée d'être prise
en tenaille par les troupes
russes.
n est déjà plein.
Cette famille quitte son
domicile pour la seconde fois
à cause de bombardements
tout près de leur maison.
Ils viennent de quitter
Sloviansk, mais ils ne savent
pas où ils vont aller.
Cette famille a quitté Lyman.
"On nous tirait dessus".
Vladimir est le chef du convoi.
"350 passagers dans ce train.
Cela fait un mois qu'il évacue
des gens de la région."
"Il y a en a eu j
4000-5000-6000 par jour,
quatre trains par jour.
Ceux qui embarquent au dernier
moment sont dans cet autobus
marqué "évacuation d'enfants".
Ce sont des invalides
ou des handicapés.
Trois wagons leur sont réservés.
L'opération est délicate.
"Pendant le voyage,
on va demander à chaque passager
où il veut aller,
qui les attend, quels sont
leurs besoins, et les aider
s'ils n'ont pas d'endroit
où rester. Il y a un medec
à bord : le Docteur Taras.
C'est son deuxième voyage.
"Dans cette invasion, l'ennemi
s'en prend aux plus dépourvus,
il faut les aider.
(sanglots)
Certains patients
sont terrorisés."
Ces wagons sont spécialement
aménagés pour les handicapés,
corridor et toilettes
plus vastes.
Quand on demande ame
où elle va, elle répond...
"Loin!"
Vladimir dit qu'il continuera
à convoyer des ges
qu'il faudra. Il donne
le signal du départ.
Le train passera d'abord
par Dnipl embarquel embarquel ea
encore des passagers.
Il prendra la dire
de Lviv, puis de la frontière
polonaise. On estime qu'il reste
25 % de la populatette
partie du Donbass. La plupart
sont des personnes âgées.
Jean-Michel Leprince,
Radio-Canada, Pokrovsk.